the g20 summit began on saturday with a
plea from the host of the gathering
italian prime minister mario draghi we
must do all we can
to overcome our differences
and we must rekindle
the spirit that led to the creation of
this group coming into the summit
leaders from the world's major economies
agreed to a minimum global corporate tax
of 15
meant to reduce abuse of offshore
loopholes
the biggest issues though are proving
the most difficult
covid19 vaccine equity and taking
effective action on the climate crisis
a draft statement from the group shows
it's struggling to get member countries
to truly commit to capping global
warming at the 1.5 degree mark a
benchmark scientists have said is
required to avoid disaster
and this comes just days before the
climate change conference in glasgow
some key leaders opted to attend only
via remote video
chinese president xi jinping made only
vague comments about china opening up
further to the world but made no mention
of china's role as a major global
polluter russian president vladimir
putin had a more pointed request on
vaccine recognition russia's sputnik
covid19 vaccine has not been approved
for use by the u.s or the european union
in hopes of reviving the iran nuclear
deal u.s president joe biden met on the
sidelines with the leaders of the uk
france and germany they later issued a
statement warning of the dangers of a
nuclear-capable iran
outside the security perimeter
protesters gathered to call attention to
various causes
thousands of protesters from disparate
groups have come out into the street
here in rome on saturday
some are calling for action on the
climate crisis others are marching
against capitalism they all have one
message though and that's for world
leaders to address global inequity and
climate change now
we're marching today because we're
asking for more concrete policies on
climate change since the g20 is
happening right now in rome the summit
will continue on sunday people will be
watching closely to see if a closing
group statement will go far enough in
addressing climate change adam rainey al
jazeera rome